[Music]
she got it from her mama Ct is looking
at the celebrity mother-daughter
look-alikes that'll make you do a
double-take
first Cindy Crawford and Kaia Gerber
kaya turned 16 over Labor Day weekend
and she's following in her mom's
modeling footsteps we have the same
mannerisms we have the same just like
the way we react to certain situations
is the same I think that's what really
shine through how much I like the oh
yeah next Reese Witherspoon and 17 year
olds Ava Philippi
they're basically twins I just love her
I'm so lucky to be her mom I just love
my life and getting to go everywhere
there's some great honor Suri Cruise
looks a lot like mom Katie Holmes as she
makes every day great and awesome and
better and I know myself more because of
her and Brielle Biermann is the spitting
image of mom Kim Zolciak even they can't
believe the resemblance I just the same
like I look on the camera I'm like I
don't know we had the same makeup artist
the same hair I don't know no what do we
look at he's a little creepy 13 year old
Apple Martin definitely takes off your
mom's when it's Paltrow and she's got
her mom's talents too she's just such a
force of nature I mean she loves acting
and singing and the songwriting but
she's also amazing at math and science
so who knows check out this side by side
of Christie Brinkley and daughter Saylor
I get a lot from her too because she has
the sense of empowerment about her that
she constantly inspires me and we can't
help but notice how similar Kate Hudson
and mom Goldie Hawn are oh my god I
think her energy is unlike sort of you
know anything else she's just shocked
right out of a cannon but her everything
she is it's quite authentic and I think
she's she's such an original she's kind
of great at what she does
you